is there room for god
in assembly theory
who's god
i like arguments for a necessary being
better than god
well i think i said it earlier
like something that has to exist
oh so you like i mean you like the
shortest path like does god need no no i
i mean i well you can go back to like
thomas aquinas and arguments for um
the existence of god but i think i think
most of the interesting theological
arguments are always
about whether something has to exist or
there was a first thing that had to
exist but i think there's a lot of
logical loopholes in those kind of
arguments well so god here meaning the
machine
that creates
that generates
the stuff
because so what i was trying to say
earlier isn't that just the universe
yeah yeah well yeah well but i there's a
difference between i i should i imagine
like a black box like a machine
yeah that's then i would be more
comfortable calling that god
because it's a machine you go into a
room and there's a thing with a button
yeah i don't like the great programmer
in the sky version can i yeah but if
it's more kind of uh
um like i don't like to think of if you
look at a cellular automata
if it if it's the cells and the rules
that doesn't feel like god that
generates a bunch of stuff but if
there's a machine
like uh that does that runs the cellular
automata and set the rules then that
feels like god
that the other sort of
in terms of terminology so i wonder if
there's like a machine that's required
to generate this universe that's very
sort of important for running this in
the lab
so as i said earlier i think i said this
earlier that i can't remember the phrase
but something like
i mean does god exist in our universe
yes
where does god exist exhaust god at
least exists in the abstraction in my in
our minds right particularly of people
who have who have religious faith they
believe in but let's then take your but
you're talking a little bit more about
generic say well
is there a mechanism beyond the universe
you're calling god i would say god
did not exist at the beginning
but he or she does now
because i'm saying the message you don't
know
he didn't exist in the beginning
so like uh
this could be us in our minds trying to
like just what listening to
gravitational waves detecting
gravitational waves it's the same thing
us trying to
uh go back further and further into our
memories to try to understand the
machines that make up
to make up us and so it's possible that
we're trying to
um
grasp at possible kind of
what kind of machines could create
uh there's a there's always a tweet
there's always a tweet
uh if the universe is a computer then
god must have built it because computers
need creators there you go
and then uh yoshibach replied
since there's something rather than
nothing perhaps existence is the default
if existence is the default that many
computers exist creator gods are
necessary computers unnecessarily
computers too i'm very confused by that
but that's an interesting idea that
existence is a default versus
non-existence i agree with that but the
rest is the response perhaps this
reasoning is incomplete that's that's
how scientists talk trash each other on
twitter apparently uh which part don't
you agree with
when he said if existence is default
then many computers exist this comes
back to the inventor and discovery
argument
i would say the universe at the
beginning wasn't capable
of computation
because there wasn't enough technology
enough states
so what you're saying is the mec if god
is a mechanism so i might actually agree
but then the thing is lots of people
seem more see god is more than the
mechanism for me god could be the causal
graph and assembly theory that creates
all the stuff the memories we know and
the fact that we can even relate to each
other is because we have the same we
share that heritage and
why we love each other or we like to see
god in each other is it's just
we
know we have a shared existence so if
the god is the mechanism that created
this whole thing
i think a lot of people see god you know
in the religious sense
as a
as that mechanism also being able to
communicate with the objects it creates
and if it's just the mechanism it won't
be able to create with object uh
communicate with objects it creates it
can only create it can't like
interact
with the uh there's versions of god that
create the universe and then left
you know
yeah like spark for for some religions
but the first spark yeah but i i think i
liked your analogy of the machine and
the rules right but
um
i think part of the problem is
you i mean we have this conception that
we can disentangle the rules from the
physical substrate right and that's the
whole thing about like software and
hardware being separate or the way
newton wrote his laws that there was
some you know like they exist outside
the universe they're not actually a
feature of the universe they don't have
to emerge out of the universe itself um
so i think if you if you merged your two
views then it gets back to the god as
the universe and then i think the the
deeper question is why does it seem like
there's meaning and purpose
and
if i think about the features of the
universe that give it the most meaning
and purpose those are the the what we
would call the living components of the
universe so if you wanted to say
god is a physically real thing which you
were saying is like an emergent property
of our minds but i would just say
you know the way the universe creates
meaning and purpose there is really a
physics there it's not like a illusory
thing and that is just what what the
physics of life is
um
is it is it possible that we've
forgotten much of the mechanisms that
created the universe
so like is so basically you know
whatever if god is that mechanism
we just leave parts of that behind well
but the universe is constantly
generating itself so if god is that
mechanism it would be that that would
still be active today i don't believe
like i'm agnostic but if i if i if i
recall would call the things i believe
in god and the way that some people
talk about god i would say that god is
you know like in the like universe now
it's not an absent thing
are you
i'm so i think there's a mislabeling
here because you're
i mean from
i mean i'm
a professional idiot um actually but but
should put that on your cv yeah
yeah yeah professionally but not
recreationally or amateur but
professionally but i think for it
i would say if you were talking about
god i mean again i'm way out way out of
my debt and i almost feel like
you but i feel quite uncomfortable
articulating but i'll try
for me a lot of people that think of god
as a consciousness a reasoning entity
that actually has causal power
and you're just human like intelligence
and you're and so you're like then
you're saying like gravity could be god
or time could be god i mean i think for
me
for my conception of time is probably as
fundamental as god because it gave rise
to human intelligence and consciousness
in which we can have this abstract
notion of god um
so i i think that
you're maybe talking about god in a very
mechanistic kind of unsophisticated
sense
whereas other people say that god is
more sophisticated and got all this you
know feelings and love and
you know
and this abstracting ability so
is that what or do you mean that do you
mean god as in this conscious entity
that decided to flick the universe into
existence
well
one of the features that god
would have is the ability to flick the
universe into existence
i you know like windows 95 i don't know
if god is windows 95 or windows xp or
windows 10 i don't know the full feature
set okay so you at the very least you
have to flick the universe into
existence and then
other features might include ability to
interact with that universe in
interesting ways
and then
how do you interact with the universe in
interesting ways you have to be able to
speak the language of its different
components
so in order to interact with humans
you have to
know how to act human-like
so so i don't i don't know
um
but it seems like
whatever mechanism created the universe
might want
to also generate
local pockets of mechanisms that can
interact with that
inject
god was lonely
yeah it was long i mean it could be just
a teenager and another
just playing a video yeah maybe well i
was gonna say i mean i i don't so this
is referring from our origin of life
engine it's like i i don't believe in
god but that doesn't mean i don't want
to be one
right
you